good morning good afternoon and hello
everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast
overcoming barriers to productivity in
hcs
an image to answer solution for
biologists
i'm alexis kraus of laperts and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labberts
and sponsored by cytiva for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
saitiba.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
william marshall senior product manager
at cellular analysis saitiva
and dr david egan ceo and co-founder
core life analytics for a complete
biography on both of our presenters
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen will you may
now begin
your presentation welcome
hello everyone my name is will marshall
i'm a senior product manager at sativa
responsible for the high content
screening portfolio
very excited today to be presenting on
the topic of
overcoming barriers to productivity and
high content
screening as a reminder it's a joint
webinar
where we'll be presenting the first half
of the talk and then handing it over to
our
friends at core life analytics for the
second portion of the session
today's talk is about overcoming some of
the challenges bottlenecks pain points
in the high content screening workflow
but before we jump into that
let's let's back up a bit and look at
what that workflow is
so at its core it's nothing more than
automated microscopy
so the acquisition stages where you're
acquiring many many pictures in
microtiter plates of many many samples
and it's far more images than you could
ever
afford time to look at and make sense of
if you're trying to understand for
example an efficacious drug to rescue
some diseased phenotype
so we need algorithms and computers to
come in and help us
with methods like object segmentation
so we want to find single cells in an
image
and we want to extract features from
those or measurements we use those terms
interchangeably
and then we want to take those
measurements or features into an
analysis step where we use statistical
methods to try to make sense and draw
conclusions and actual
insights from the images
so another way to to break this down
it's a little bit
less granular even is is in the two
parts image analysis and downstream
analysis
in image analysis we're really just
converting that information into pixels
into a more structured
format that's more friendly to applying
these statistical analyses
and then the job of the downstream
analysis is really to take
all that very high dimensional data
reduce it down to something that we can
interpret and understand
to draw a conclusion and move on to the
next step in our research project
if we go back and look at the first
example
from the actual patent for high content
analysis
we we actually see that it's actually
quite low content
so it's nothing more than a true nuclear
translocation assay
which is very valuable in itself but
it's a pretty simplistic way to look at
how biology responds
to things like small molecule
perturbation or genetic modifications
so if we flash forward to today
this is much more representative of what
people are doing with respect to high
content screening
and it's much more comprehensive when it
comes to
understanding and describing a phenotype
it's leveraging
all the content in the image as opposed
to just a single feature like where is
the intensity
is it in the nucleus or in the cytoplasm
instead of extracting one feature or
taking a ratio of some
different measurements it's very high
content
in fact we're extracting thousands of
features
for every cell within an image and it
doesn't require that we know
what the target is for a drug it doesn't
require that we
understand fully the function of a gene
it's simply looking for
differences between two different
conditions
by leveraging all the information rich
content that you see in a picture
so kind of what what sets the stage for
the rest of the talk is that assay
complexity is continually increasing
and as you extract more and more
information from
from an individual cell the data becomes
overwhelming
so what are we going to do with this how
are we going to make
sense of all this this information
distill it down to something that's
actionable well
it's very hard using our current methods
we've outgrown the capabilities of these
methods
so can we look for a new technology
something that's
inherently good at solving these types
of problems and machine learning is
actually capable of doing exactly that
so this is from a review article
and i showed three different examples
and we start with a figure on the left
so using machine learning this group was
able to
do some hierarchical clustering on the
phenotypic profiles extracting all this
content-rich information
from individual cells in a massive high
content screen
and then perform the same type of
clustering method on
the chemical compound structures and the
different features associated with those
structures and what they see is strong
correlation between the phenotypic
profiles
and the clusters that are representing
chemical compounds with similar
structures so what this means is
the chemical structure is very
predictive
of the phenotype it will generate when
you put it into cells
in the interest of time i won't go
through all the possibilities this
creates but you can imagine
what this means for being able to
understand what is a subset of molecules
that might be efficacious against some
disease state
and in the center example we're looking
at a supervised machine learning
object classification example where the
researchers have set up an rna eye
screen to understand
the function of certain genes that have
an unknown function
and what they see whenever they group
these cells
very accurately by their phenotype is
that the
functions of the genes that drive the
generation of these phenotypes
cluster together so what that means is
if you have an
a gene with an unknown function but you
have other genes with a known function
you can use this phenotypic readout to
then infer something about that gene
with an unknown function which is quite
powerful
and all of this in the first two
examples only works because
of the ability to use all the content in
an image
to describe the phenotype take a look at
example three
this is using deep convolutional neural
networks which is the form of machine
learning
that has the advantage especially with
images that it learns the features that
are the most important
so those were just three examples on the
left i showed some bullet points of all
the different
places where people are using different
types of machine learning methods
to improve different steps in the high
content screening workflow that you see
on the right
and if there are so many options it can
kind of be overwhelming
as to where do we start and at sativa
my team and i really look for where we
can make the biggest impact we start
there
and see where to go next so we've
settled on
one kind of concept that kind of guides
us and that's
high content screening is about
leveraging the most content
possible and then making sure that
content
is of some degree of quality before we
go into the downstream analysis step
so let's first start with uh some more
examples
on improving our ability to leverage
content
and we'll focus on a truly phenotypic
analysis
so let's take a look at a typical
classification workflow classification
being
how we divide up the data set into
subpopulations based on the phenotype
so this is an example of let's say
current state
or the way that people have performed a
classification step
in the recent years so it's very similar
to what you might be familiar with
with flow cytometry you take a single
feature like the intensity of objects as
it passes through the laser beam
and you can generate tons of different
data points
very quickly so you have a lot of data
to work with
and then on a scatter plot or a
histogram as i show here
the job is to add gates to that plot
and segregate these different
subpopulations but this requires the
user to select the right features from
an image that actually describe this
more complex phenotype than just the
intensity
you have to apply all of these things in
the right logical order if you're
building some complicated decision trees
the problem gets harder
then at each step in this you have to
threshold on these different histograms
or on on your scatter plot and this can
be somewhat of an
arbitrary process if i move that
threshold left or right
a little bit does it actually change the
end result
so inherently it's low content that's
that's the real problem with it and as
we
increase the content to describe the
phenotypic
or the phenotype accurately it starts to
become
unmanageable for a person it's too many
dimensions in the data
set so let's let's switch this figure up
and and draw it up is if we use some
machine learning
so the interaction between the human and
the analysis problem is much
different as opposed to having to worry
about the logic what measurements are
correct and where to set those
thresholds we leave that problem to the
computer
and instead we just give it examples of
a
class of a cell and then another class
and it figures out how to differentiate
between those classes so the computer is
learning the most appropriate features
and it has the extra advantage that it
can learn the right combination of the
features
which is something that's quite
challenging for a human it's a data
driven approach
and statistics help guide us on where
that threshold can be
and statistics work the way that they
work they're not biased to
the same kind of considerations that
humans are
and it's high content so as the problem
gets increasingly harder
it becomes much more difficult than just
separating these interphase and
metaphase cells
the the method can keep up with the
complexity
if it has the right features fed into it
so at sativa we we built our own version
of a trainable classifier object level
classifier
it's called phenoglyphs it's a module in
our incarta image
analysis software and just like i
described
it it has the same benefits of a machine
learning based classifier
but we've added on our extra spin to it
which is we start with an unsupervised
step
so it becomes even more inherently
unbiased
the first step is to just let the
computer find natural patch
patterns in the data and return that to
the user
so it breaks up the data set into
groups of things that look visually
similar and then
you tell the machine if it did a good
job or not
you're not even clicking on individual
cells you're just
rewarding the computer when it did a
good job and you're penalizing it when
it
did a bad job and it's an iterative
process where it learns
a classification model based on the
features that it was given
until you confirm that it's accurate and
because it's using
all of the measurements and all of the
descriptive features to just
describe the phenotype it's much more
sensitive
to resolve subtle phenotypic differences
so when we put this in practice in the
field
we were not disappointed this is a
collaboration from several years ago
with galapagos it's a biotech in the
netherlands
where they were looking at finding drug
targets
to come up with therapies for systematic
sclerosis and they want to generate a
high content screen
in these diseased human cell uh human
skin cell fibroblasts
and they know from the literature the
fibroblasts to myofibrillate transition
is potentially very important
understanding this disease
on the right in the top figure i show
the image it's quite complex it's
multiple fluorescent markers so there's
a ton of content to leverage
okay so again back to the content that
we can take advantage of to understand
what happens whenever we
use an srna for example to knock out a
gene
if the cells look the same then probably
that's not an important gene involved in
the pathway involved in this fmt
transition
okay but if we do get some kind of
change whether it be very strong or
subtle then that might be a gene of
importance so
on the bottom right i show how they
array their controls
and for the purposes of this talk let's
divide it into two groups
the non-treated group in the treaty
group treaty group being the blue
uh in the red wells the green being the
non-treated wells
and now i want to draw your attention to
the heat maps
that we show here so it's comparing
two methods it's what happens when we
take a conventional method where we use
one feature
to try to predict whether or not a
srna treatment knocks out a gene and
whether that gene is implicated in this
process that generates a phenotype
and it's pretty noisy maybe you can see
the hint
of the controls standing out from the
background
but basically it's noise if you look at
the
heat map on the left this is from
phenoplus
where it's using all the content in the
image to say do you
really look like a non-treated cell or
do you look like
something else and you can clearly see
that the controls are well separated
from the rest of the population you
start to see hints of wells
that are somewhere in between so those
are your your targets for
potential hits and when they do that hit
analysis on this
pilot study they find that actually both
methods give you
1.5 hit rate but they don't agree on
what the hits
are which makes you ask the question
which method do you trust
we already have an indication from the
heat maps that the
phenotypic approach might work better
than the
simple univariate hit scoring
but if we take a look at something like
a statistical metric that tells us the
confidence
or the robustness of our acid like a z
prime then it becomes much more clear
so the orange bars represent the z prime
values
from the single univariate feature based
method the intensity scoring method
and the green represent the result when
they use phenoglyphs
to capture much more information
and bring that into the analysis and you
see that the z prime
increases by at least a factor of two so
i'll stop here on leveraging content
and we'll go upstream in the workflow
now we'll talk about the features that
go
in to something like a machine learning
classifier
so segmentation is the first step so
reliable quantitative data is vital for
every
downstream step in that workflow
segmentation being the first
if you have errors that are going to
propagate through the rest of your
analysis
some degree of error is okay it's going
to happen segmentation
is a very challenging problem and
ultimately there is no right answer
but at some point like in the
phenoglyphs example i showed earlier
you get to a point where the air adds up
or
the method doesn't stand up to the
complexity of the assay and you start to
miss things that are very important
and that we would obviously see with our
eyes and our brain if we had time to
actually as a human go in and look at
all the pictures that we generate
and why is it challenging well
in microscope images of cells
or tissues objects are crowded it's a
complex image they have different sizes
and shapes
we're often struggling from poor signal
to noise biomarkers fluorescent
biomarkers aren't perfect
we have low contrast and we're
resolution limited
not to mention we have high phenotypic
variability
this can come from the perturbations
we're adding to the sample like drugs
or it can just be natural heterogeneity
in the cell type itself
and that's a problem for signal
processing methods
they are built to focus on one structure
and they're really biased by some prior
information about what that structure
should look like
so what happens so these traditional
signal
processing methods are inherently now in
the context of the
types of research we're doing today
unreliable they're unflexible
and they're inaccessible if they're
unreliable
that means you're getting garbage out of
your image analysis
and that's going to go into your
downstream analysis where ultimately you
draw a conclusion so the robustness and
sensitivity of your assay
is going to be reduced they're
inflexible you're probably not working
on
one experiment in your lab
you might be working in different
biological models
you might be working on different types
of experiments to perturb those
individual samples and they're going to
look different
if your algorithms are not flexible
enough to handle that variation
you're going to have a limitation there
so what do people do they go get
numerous software tools they get
custom coding is is another way to solve
the problem but that makes it
inaccessible and when you get to the
level where you have to be a programmer
you're no longer focused on your biology
okay so it's about where do you invest
your time so
is there a way that we can solve all
three of these kind of different
problems in the workflow in the
segmentation piece at least
in one shot and deep learning was
something we were very interested
in and we built a product around it and
we're very happy with how it's turned
out
so it's another module for uncarva
software it's called synap which is an
acronym for
segmentation is not a problem it works
with any type of data it's highly
flexible including bright field which is
always a challenge for signal processing
methods
it's high accuracy it maintains that
even when things are
low signal to noise when objects are
tightly packed and clumped
it's not sensitivity sensitive to the
phenotypic variability which is a
very important thing given that's what
you're trying to study
and it doesn't require any image
analysis expertise
unlike these more simplistic methods
where you have to be an expert at
configuring the parameters or understand
how these algorithms work
to be able to use them successfully this
is like an adult coloring book
where you actually just draw on the
image and the computer figures out how
to
draw on the image in the same behavior
so not only
is it more accurate at solving the
problem and better equipped to handle
the challenge
it's also easier for the research to
implement the strategy
on the left here i show a wound healing
assay
and just to show off the flexibility
this is not even a single cell
application
in fact we see these two converging cell
fronts coming together
and we're actually segmenting the gap in
between them
to learn something from the kinetics or
the rate at which these two things come
together
and it's the exact same algorithm that
we use to solve the problem that you see
in the middle
which is typical cell culture over time
as these live cells are dividing they're
changing shape morphology
again that's the phenotypic variability
and
it has no issue handling this complexity
it doesn't pick up the false positives
and the junk in the background that look
quite similar to a cell
they have the same intensity properties
or morphology properties
potentially but it learns from the
context just like our eyes and our brain
do
on the right is is my favorite example
this is an extremely
hard problem we'll go into more detail
on that later
okay so again this is a new module
in our image analysis software
and here are some examples that i'll
walk you through from
interacting and collaborating with our
different customers in the early days of
building this product
so back to the image of the vacuoles so
vacuoles we probably all know what they
are there's these voids these gaps
where the cell is upset and is trying to
patch things up and move them out of the
cell so
as i stated before this is one of my
favorite examples of what
synap can do and the reason it's one of
my favorite examples is
we tried making an algorithm to solve
this problem it's actually extremely
complicated
it's complicated not just because things
are out of focus and blurry
we have methods to deal with that but
but
being blurry and out of focus and having
this background fluorescence
is really a mess when you add on the
fact that
all the structures these vacuoles are at
different sizes and there are other
things in the image
like the nucleus that also excludes the
fluorescence
they look very very very similar and
when you work with a signal processing
method it doesn't have the context to
know the difference between some
structure that looks like that
and a true vacuole so it's highly
sensitive it's specific
and robust against false positive
detection
the process to create this result was
intuitive it wasn't the
user learning how to configure an
algorithm
to create this result it was the
computer
learning what the biologist called the
true vacuole
versus something else and it figured out
the rest for you
and that makes it accessible this
researcher
didn't spend years learning
image analysis techniques again i go
back to the analogy of an adult coloring
book they simply said
what is a true vacuole what pixels are
not in a vacuole
it figured out the rest i'll come back
to flexibility again and now i show
three examples that are all quite
different
on the left is what i'll call bright
field analysis the data is right field
the analysis is really single cell
segmentation over time watching these
live cells
divide and move around um
it's challenging because it's bright
field but again the point is
flexibility it's the same algorithm it's
the same workflow that generates the
result that you see
in the middle figure which is a bread
and butter high content screen
this is a cell paint example it's
actually from the data set
that went into the original publication
where
quality control of the information that
goes into the downstream
stream machine learning step that
generates these phenotypic profiles
is very very important and even though
the cells are crowded and the data
quality is not that great
synap is able to figure out how to
segment these objects as well as i can
by eye and then something
that i'll call a microscopy application
it's not something you see in high
content screening
it's from a super resolution image and
it doesn't matter
that the content is is completely
different from the other two examples
again it's the same workflow and
algorithm where if you wanted to study
individual mitochondria in your
data is an image it works just as well
and now let's move into what i'll call a
case study so
we we see that it can do pretty amazing
things with respect to segmentation but
the question is does it matter
so this is an assay where the goal
essentially is to count spots
and spot detection algorithms
are very subject to false positive
detection because
being a spot is relative if you're a
bright point
around dim pixels then you could be a
spot but are you a real spot
so i would focus my attention now to the
right side of the slide
where i just show the pictures on the
top i show the
one one condition using a conventional
segmentation method on the right i show
a treaty case the maximal dose case
where we don't expect to see any spots
at all
and you see that we pick up a lot and
that's because the
researcher configuring the algorithm
optimized it for one condition which is
to pick up spots
and then try to modify the parameters to
not detect spots in the maximal dose
case
but at some point if they optimize it
too much for the maximal dose case
they start to miss spots in the
non-treated case
take a look at that in contrast when we
use
synap that's using context from the
entire image as opposed to
just local intensity information so it's
doing equally as good job at picking up
all the spots
in the non-treaty case but not subject
to the false positive errors that you
see
in the maximal dose case and again if we
use our z prime
statistic to say doesn't matter you
actually get a
drastic improvement in your z prime
score
so it's reliable it's flexible and
accessible it doesn't
require you to be an image analysis
expert it doesn't require you to
parameterize things where you're subject
to some kind of bias where it's not
going to work well in one treatment
you might get a false positive you might
miss something
that's actually really important you're
never going to know about it
again the whole point is to leverage the
content in the image and increase the
quality of it
and at the end of the day the extra
benefit is
it's easy to use it's one workflow it's
flexible
you can use it against any image
analysis problem
and maintain the same level of accuracy
so i've described our product that helps
with leveraging content
our product that helps with the inputs
that goes into that
content that you're going to use to make
actionable decisions so when we pair
them up we kind of have an
end-to-end machine learning workflow
and let's take a look at an example
where we put this into practice
so this is recent work with a group out
at the university of michigan
where their biological model is candida
and candida live in our guts
evidently and they typically have a
yeast morphology and that's fine they
can live in our gut and we don't have a
problem
but they can go through this reversible
morphological change into a phenotype
that's more elongated
and those more elongated forms are
actually problematic
they allow them to infiltrate other
tissues in the body and cause infection
so the group wanted to know if we could
set up a high contact screen
that was robust at detecting these
phenotypes so that they could go
work on environmental conditions hit it
with different drugs and see if they can
modulate the
natural behavior of the cell type and
again i would draw probably our
attention to the images here
on the left we have one method which
i'll call a traditional method we use a
signal processing algorithm to segment
these cells as best as we can
on the right we show our deep learning
module synap during the segmentation
the way the experiment was set up is
half the wells were all one control
where we expect
most of the cells to be yeast we haven't
done anything to them
the other half was set up in a way that
we
would expect an enrichment of the
elongated phenotypes
so there was a a change in how the the
cells were
prepped or cultured okay and if you look
at the graphs at the bottom
with the deep learning method we see
exactly that you see that in the
negative control we have almost
exclusively something like 90 percent
yeast morphology and in the what i'll
call a positive control
we almost have none of them and we are
enriched
mostly with the hypha phenotype and some
of the
pseudohyphen you don't see those same
results
when you use traditional methods and
it's not because the image is different
the images are the same
take a look at the image of the
segmentation using the traditional
method there's tons of errors there
there's under segmentation over
segmentation
and detection errors so if we're
completely missing cells
or we're breaking up these elongated
cells or we're merging together
cells that are actually two different
cells the features we extract from those
segmented
objects are no longer going to represent
the actual
information content in the image and we
get it
we get a graph out of it we get a result
it's just not very useful it's not very
informative
it's only when we reduce those errors to
a certain degree
that we actually have a robust assay
that's worth using
to understand this biological process
so i hope you've enjoyed hearing about
our piece of the puzzle on how to make
this process
of high content screening in this
workflow
more efficient more productive using
machine learning
i want to turn it over to our friends at
core life
analytics who have a very interesting
product that that we think you're you're
going to be very excited to hear about
so david i'll turn it over to you
hello everyone my name is david egan and
i'm the ceo of
core life analytics first off i'd like
to thank will marshall and all our
friends at saitiva
for the opportunity to present here core
life analytics was started by myself and
my co-founder veenandompta
with the goal of solving this problem
if you make even partial use of the
capabilities of the incel and karate
platform
you're going to end up with a lot of
numeric data
there's a lot of knowledge on this data
but to extract it biologists often have
to hand it off to data science
specialists
this inevitably leads to delays and
possibly a sub-optimal analysis
the data scientist may not have an
in-depth understanding
of the complex biologies that are now
being used in high content experiments
we have solved this problem by
developing a web-based data analytics
platform called stratominer
stratominer allows biologists to
independently mine the numeric data
generated by encarta it does this by
guiding them through an intuitive data
mining workflow
they can upload their data separate
metadata from analytical data
discard data that isn't useful and then
carry out quality control
they can now move on to statistical
methods such as plate normalization
data transformation and scaling and then
on to more advanced data reduction
methods
the platform allows users to make use of
parts or
all of the data to generate phenotypic
profiles
and to investigate these using
unsupervised methods or supervised
methods such as machine learning
at the end of the day in the same way
that incarta democratizes
advanced image analysis we're
democratizing advanced statistics and
data science
strata miner is a cloud deployed
platform
each of our customers has their own
deployment of strataminer
they can access this through a strength
a standard web browser
and of course this is ideal in these
days of de-densification
when most scientists are only allowed on
premises to carry out bench work
the benefits of strata minor become very
obvious to users
it accelerates analysis cycles reduces
the burden on their data science
specialists
and most importantly gives the user far
deeper insights
into their data for in-cell users
strataminer completes the high content
analysis pipeline
allowing them to rapidly turn images
into knowledge
in the next section i want to give you
an overview of how that actually works
in the stratominer software
the data from encarta can be loaded
directly into strataminer without any
modification
this can be one plate or a hundred
plates the first thing we do is identify
what is metadata
and what is your analytical data we can
also give you an opportunity to merge
new metadata with your data set
as you will see later this can be
extremely useful
next we help you to easily remove
useless measurements
here's an example of something that has
useful information
this one doesn't as its uniform across
the whole experiment
we have a very powerful module that
helps you to build and manage plate maps
you can copy modify and share them with
your colleagues
now we give you an opportunity to carry
out quality control on your data
you get access to a highly interactive
plotting technology that we call visual
data mining
this is a great place to identify and
diagnose problems with your experiment
you can calculate plate metrics such as
z prime and remove outlier wells
all of this i just described as the data
wrangling and qc
that actually take the most time in data
analytics with stratominer however
you can do it in just a few minutes in
the next section of the workflow we
start to get into the data science
the initial part of this will be
familiar we carry out plate
normalization
against your control wells of choice
then we move on to steps that are
suggested if you want to make use of a
lot of incarta measurements for
phenotypic analysis
we help you to transform the data to
account for heavily skewed measurements
like this
we also allow you to scale your data
using a z-score
or a robust z-score as i said however
these steps are optional if you're doing
a simple analysis
with one or a few measurements you can
skip them next
we move on to dimensionality reduction
this is essential if you're doing real
phenotypic analysis with a large number
of features
if you're doing for example cell
painting you really need to do this
we offer a number of different methods
the most familiar is principal component
analysis
one of the most important reasons for
carrying out dimensionality reduction
is to decrease redundancy in the data
this essentially allows all the
phenotypic changes to become visible
even if some are represented by just a
small number of measurements
here's a plot that highlights the
similarities between all the
measurements in this data set
these yellow blobs are groups of
measurements that are saying essentially
the same thing
strataminer with this scree plot helps
you to figure out how you can reduce
this data
while still capturing as much of the
variance as possible in the reduced data
set
what you end up with is a smaller data
set with all the important
information still there another way in
which dimensionality reduction helps
is by exposing biological connections
between different measurements in the
data set
you can see how different principal
components for example
are lit up by different types of
mechanism of action
now we get onto the fun stuff
stratiminer can help you to use your
reduced data set
to identify phenotypic outliers wells
that look
different from your negative control for
example or it can also help you to
identify phenosimolars
things that are similar to for example a
tool compound
we do this by using what we call a
distance score
in this 3d plot of the scores from three
principal components
you can see how these wells here are far
away
from the negative controls here we can
calculate this distance
and it's a measure of the strength of
the phenotype this is
just shown here in three dimensions but
you can also do this in 11 or
n dimensions here we are asking the
simple question
what samples are different from our
negative controls
you can see that all of our positives
are outliers and in our samples
you can see ones down here that are
doing nothing
and then you can see here outliers
things that are phenotypically different
once we have identified these outliers
we can use hierarchical clustering
to separate them according to the
profile of the component scores
by doing this we are separating them by
phenotype
and a potentially by mechanism of action
this combination of distance score and
clustering is what we call our
unsupervised profiling method
strataminer also allows you to use
artificial intelligence
a supervised method if you use the cell
resolution data from encarta
you can build machine learning models
here strataminer has built a three-class
random forest
machine learning model to help the user
to rank all the wells according to
similarity to docetaxel
doxorubicin and the untreated controls
stridominer also has a simple app for
dose response this is very useful
especially if you are generating large
numbers of dose response curves
as we'll see later it can also be used
in a clever way with phenotypic data
one thing i'd like to make clear is that
strataminer is not just useful for
highly complex data you can also use it
for single measurement data such as that
from
traditional high throughput screens it's
also useful
for multiplexing or you can do something
as complex as cell painting
we'll show you within carta how adding
more advanced methods
can help you to get better quality data
and more knowledge from the data
it's just the same with strataminer so
i'd like to show you how we can do this
with an encarted data set
the example i'm going to use is a
publicly available data set that we know
very well at core life analytics
it was originally published by neil
carrer at the university of edinburgh
we think of it as cell painting light as
it's three of the five
cell painting labels in this study
cancer relevant
drugs and inhibitors with various
mechanisms of action were tested
in eight doses the images from the
screen are available at the broad
institute bioimage benchmark collection
so we asked will to help us to analyze
these images using incarta
here i'll show you a subset of that data
set with 30 compounds
the positive control for this screen is
the microtubule stabilizer
taxol first let's do a very simple
analysis
let's pretend we're looking for
compounds with the same mechanism of
action as taxol
if we look at dmso images versus taxol
images
there's an obvious difference here the
intensity of the tubulin staining is
much higher in the taxol images
so let's pick an obvious measure the
total intensity in the tubulin channel
for our analysis but as you can see here
when we plot the negative and positive
wells
there is only about a 1.5 times diff
difference between
the negatives and the texol wells for
this measurement
and the z prime is only 0.14
unsurprisingly if we look at the screen
using this metric
it's not too impressive we pick up
microtubule compounds but we
we would worry if they were real due to
the poor z prime
and there are a bunch of compounds with
other mechanisms of action in here
it just doesn't look very trustworthy
within carter however we can calculate
many more measurements and in strata
minor
we can use vdm qc to find one that has
this higher z prime here's one
with a median z prime of 0.53
so if we look at analysis using this
single feature
it looks a lot better to a screener as
well as taxol
we pick up another taxane dosataxel
and we also pick up another microtubule
compound with a very different structure
epochal and b we can still see
compounds with other mechanisms of
action however so that's still a concern
one of them is latrunculin b let's have
a closer look at that
this highlights a problem with our
better but still simplistic analysis
it's clear from the images that this
latrunculin b gives a
very different phenotype to taxol but
you can see while it still turns up in
our hit list
there is intense tubulin staining but i
think we can do better
let's make a use of all the measurements
that incarta can generate
at cellular resolution now this is
something you're not going to be able to
handle in microsoft excel
in strataminer however we can use the ai
functionality
to build a two class two class machine
learning model
and we can then use this model to rank
every well in the experiment
according to similarity to taxol or dmso
now this looks like a very specific
assay
we're now identifying hits based on the
overall taxol phenotype
not just one measurement and you can see
that the trunculin b
is now no longer in the hit list we do
still have
two confining hits however trichostatin
a hdac inhibitor and midaxantrone which
is annotated as being involved in dna
replication and damage
a little poking around in the literature
however shows that there is a reason to
believe that they should be there
trichostatin causes the acetylation of
microtubules
and medexantrone has been shown also
shown to be effect
microtubule assembly so this really
demonstrates nicely the advantages of
using all the data
and more advanced analytical methods
this was a very focused question that we
were asking in this example
but we can also use strataminer in a
very exploratory fashion
here we use our unsupervised method to
calculate the distance scores
from the negatives for all wells in the
screen
we can plot these distance scores
against dose to rapidly identify
bioactive compounds
here you can see the phenotype coming up
as the dose increases
and we can then use the clustering
functionality to identify interesting
phenotypes
amongst these bioactives
finally we can go back to our plate maps
label interesting wells as new classes
for machine learning
and then identify similar wells to these
so in the last few minutes what i'd like
to do is just give you a short
demonstration of the strata miner
software itself
so here i am i can log into our demo
deployment
of strataminer at cla.strataminer.com
so when we log in then
here's the hc strataminer app our main
app and here's that app that i mentioned
for dose response data and what we can
do is we can jump straight into that
experiment that i was showing you
in the presentation with the incarnated
data
and so here this is where you can access
this workflow
and you'll recognize these icons from
one of the first slides that i showed
here is the upload data section then we
have this various section for dealing
with all the metadata
throwing out the garbage then here is
where we are now is where we can merge
some metadata
so what we've done is we've imported a
file that has some
external metadata that we can merge with
our raw data here we have a thing called
a reagent class
we have compound names concentrations
say
some sort of corporate identifier and
here's the mechanism of action
in a plate id and what we do is we
actually merge
through this plate id and we can set
that up here
then tell the system that we want to use
the synonym as a reagent id
and then the metadata is now merged and
we hit save and continue so now we move
on to that place where we can manage
our plate maps and as i said we have a
very
you know sophisticated module here that
allows us to
to modify copy share our various
plate maps so in this case what we have
here is we have a number of different
plate maps for the same experiment
so the basic plate map looks like this
okay
but then we also have some additional
plate maps like this one for plate
number two
and we have some of these wells here
that are labeled so these are some of
the
compounds that i was talking about
earlier on here's the trunkline wells
doxorubicin then we also have for plate
four
we have here some dosataxel
wells that are labeled and once we've
added our plate maps
then again we can move on and now we're
onto this
quality control stage that i mentioned
where there's a lot of this
visual data mining technology and so
here by default what we have
is you know we can plot
these you know what we call a default
feature and this was
that one that gave us the high z prime
and the actual
object id which is representative of the
cell number
and you can see here we can turn on and
off the various reagent classes
let's for example just look at our
negatives and our positives
and then we can do things like we can
let's say remove outliers let's say we
want to get rid of these guys
now they've been removed from the
analysis but we can actually still see
where they are we have a new class here
called removed
and there we can see the ones that we
removed and actually we can even turn
them back
into samples let's say we want to turn
these guys back into what they were
we can reset them
here's that tab where we can calculate
our z
primes see how we do that
and then you can see here how we can
sort
and sort our features according to the z
prime
to figure out which one would be the
best if we wanted to do a simple
analysis
then after this what we could do is i
said move on and do these normalization
transformation and scaling
but let's jump ahead now because we've
already done that and let's jump ahead
and look at
the dimensionality reduction
so first of all what we can do is we can
do this previous step
and this is where we figure out how many
principal components we should actually
calculate
here's our correlation plot that shows
us the correlation between all the
different features
you see these big blobs of yellow
similarity
and then here is that scree plot and
this is the plot that helps us to decide
how many components should we calculate
so here this indicating that we should
probably calculate 11 components because
essentially
this is measuring the amount of variance
that we're including
as we calculate more and more components
down here
there's no point in calculating any more
than 11.
so then we can dial in 11 and then
actually carry out that
data reduction or dimensionality
reduction and calculate 11 different
principal components so let's look at
these
and here you can see we can flick
through each component
and what we can see here are the
features or measurements
that are loading most significantly on
each of the components
and this is what i mentioned is you know
the biology coming out
in the data reduction
also what we can see here is how these
various classes that we've defined
how they signal through the various
different components
if we look at here component one we can
see that
these labeled wells here they're
latrunculin
they give a very high signal for
component one
but if we look at component two now
this one taxol seems to be given the
highest signal
so now what we can do is we can move on
and let's go
and have a look at the next step and
again this is more
visual data mining that again allows us
to mine the data but now we can actually
have a look at all the various different
components and so here this is more
powerful that we have various different
visualizations that you can plot here
there is a heat map
and then down here we have our 3d
scatter plot
so let's look at this and what we'll do
is now we're going to look at the first
three
principal components
and now this is where you can see this
effect of
the distance score so you can see here
our negative controls and then
you can see the scatter in our positives
out here
and then you can see these are some of
the other compounds that we have labeled
up here we have the
you know latrunculin compounds down here
you have the doxorubicin compounds
so you can see how far away they are
from the negatives and you can see that
they are in different
areas in three-dimensional space
indicating that they actually have
different phenotypes
now we go to this selection section
where we do our hit picking and our
profiling
this is this unsupervised method and so
now
what we can do is let's ask a more
sophisticated question
let's see what wells are most similar to
doxorubicin
and so what we can do is we can
calculate the distance from those
doxorubicin wells
and then see what happens there
so now down here we see
our doxorubicin and then what's over
here we can see
doxorubicin doxorubicin gliomycin
hydroxyurea
so these are other flux uridine so these
are other dna damaging agents
and so you can see that they are the
ones that are closest to
uh to doxorubicin now of course we can
do a similar thing
using machine learning so what we'll do
now is let's set up
a three class model with
dosatox dosataxel doxorubicin
and the negative controls and now
this let's do the same thing let's look
for things that are similar to jackson
rubison
and see if we get something similar
so here's our model we can see the
accuracy is 95 percent
and then down here we see the results of
it here of course doxorubicin is high
and then again we can see for the colon
bleomice and our various dna damaging
agents popping up
so i think this gives you a very nice
example of
how easy it is to run the analysis in
strata miner
and how you can easily handle larger
numbers of features
and then move back and forth in the
workflow to get the most information
the most possible knowledge out of your
data
this approach of generating as many
measurements as you can and having easy
access to advanced methods to mine them
gives one major benefit if you're simply
extracting a single measurement from an
experiment
you have to iterate over experiments in
order to generate new knowledge
with the types of biological systems
that are commonly used now
3d models patient drive cell lines this
can get very
very expensive
within carta and stratiminer however you
can iterate over the analysis
measure everything that you can at high
resolution
and then you can ask multiple questions
of the data set
strata mining makes this very easy
because you can easily jump back and
forth within the workflow
new information generated can be merged
as new metadata
to enrich the analysis
you can also use the information to
rapidly refine your image analysis
this is especially valuable in the assay
development and piloting
stages if you'd like to know more about
the stratominer platform you go to our
website
or if you contact us at one of these
emails we'll get back to you
with that i'd like to thank you all for
joining and i'll hand over to will
marshall now to
wrap up
all right david thank you very much for
the excellent presentation
and a big congratulations to you and
your team over at core life analytics on
stratominer
an excellent application that really
starts to address those pain points
you really feel when doing this type of
high dimensional data analysis
especially at scale so we'll wrap up
today with our last slide
we hope you've enjoyed the presentation
we were excited to
tell you about our two different
software packages
and we just want to leave you with the
fact that they're very complementary
both of them are built around the core
principle of getting the analysis
back in the hands of the people doing
the research and we accomplish this
both with intuitive design where you're
interacting
with the software with the skill sets
that you have in a very natural way
as well as new technologies such as
machine learning
that are really built to handle these
types of problems
as opposed to some of the more
simplistic
image based analysis that we've been
performing
over the past few decades if you want
more information about our products you
can visit our websites
you can reach out to your local sativa
representative
and they'll be able to point you in the
right direction whether you're looking
for just more information
or want to get in touch with us about a
demonstration in more detail
with either of the software packages
thank you very much
have a good day
thank you and david for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
this one will go to you will our first
question is
is this hcs tech is it suitable for
digital mammogram images
uh yeah so i can take that one um
the so high content screening is
typically done
on cell culture um
in a you know biological research lab
um but the methods to analyze the images
the segmentation approaches and and then
making sense of the features in the
image that is the same technology you
would use
for medical images for example the the
digital mammogram images
but with high content screening you you
wouldn't um
you wouldn't be taking pictures of
people um they're set up to be
fluorescent microscopes typically
um but the analysis methods yes they're
the same that that people use
in the medical engine space
perfect thank you so much will for that
um
so our next question um david let's send
it over to you
so what library do you use for the moa
information
um the the mechanism of action
annotations for that
uh experiment actually were in the uh
they were in the publication uh so
that's where that came from
perfect thank you so much for that
clarification so it looks like we have
time for maybe one or two more questions
but i do want to remind our audience
that any questions we're unable to
answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
so let's move on to our next question
how many
images are needed to train a machine
learning algorithm
for segmentation and what metric is used
to evaluate the segmentation accuracy
uh so that's that's probably for me so
it it depends there's there's not really
a good answer for how many images but
with something like deep learning
you would expect that typically a lot of
data is needed
with with our product though we've we've
provided some pre-trained models so
we've kind of done the heavy lifting
where you just need to provide a few
examples from your data set
to fine-tune the network work optimally
on your data
and how we kind of evaluate it
uh segmentation there's lots of
different metrics that people have used
in the literature
the intersection over union metric is is
one
but at the end of the day it's kind of
best assessed
in a validation step where you you have
some known
um expected outcome in your data set
and if your analysis gives you that
outcome then then you infer that your
segmentation is good enough
segmentation itself i don't think
there's a lot of value in evaluating
just the accuracy
unless you're trying to win a
segmentation competition
and maybe you know that's a that's a
really good way to think about the
workflow that david proposed where you
can use the downstream analysis
to infer how you might configure your
upstream image analysis
and with things being so fast and
straddle minor to quickly
generate a new result you could quickly
iterate
between tuning your or optimizing your
segmentation by training it more
and then quickly looking at the end
result does it get better
if you add more images to your training
set for example
perfect thank you thank you so much for
that um
looks like we have time for let's
squeeze one more question in for you
guys
um let's take a look um
all righty um
let's go
let's go to this one so um david i
believe
i believe this one is for you so can i
use
strataminer to analyze data from time
course
experiments
uh yes you can there's a number of
different ways
uh uh you can do that but um
what we what we can do with strataminer
is if if you have a column in there
that in your data that gives the the
time then you can use this to either
run all your data together or what you
can do is you can actually split up the
data so that each time point
is a separate place and then you can
analyze all that and strata miner and
treat each time point is a separate
plate analyze the data and then later on
uh take that data and then you can
process it
and do um you know curves based on time
things like that so yeah it's pretty
straightforward to run the
time course experiments perfect thank
you so much for that
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank will
and david for their time today and their
important research
we would also like to thank labyrinths
and our sponsor cytiva
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand labs
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
that's all for now thank you so much for
joining us and
until next time bye bye everyone